our phones can be a double-edged sword
they allow us to have our groceries be
brought right to our door and pay bills
without ever needing to drive anywhere
but they can also be time sucking
vampires that Rob us of precious moments
in life
and while they're meant to improve our
productivity
often the constant beeps and
never-ending scrolling end up doing
exactly the opposite
and we become ever distracted and find
it difficult to be productive hey guys
I'm Jesse and today I'm going to be
sharing with you how I organize my phone
in a way that helps minimize
distractions and improve productivity so
I'll share with you the 10 tips that I
use to help me use my phone in a way
that adds value to my life rather than
create addictive phone habits this is
actually a two-part video so if you want
to see how I actually organize my phone
to keep it minimal and clutter free and
I'll leave that video down in the
description box below and if you want to
see more videos on minimalism and living
life more fully with less be sure to
subscribe for more positive videos like
these tip number one is to declutter
your apps the first thing that I did
when I purchased my new phone is that I
went in and I deleted any of the apps
that came with the phone that I knew I
wasn't going to be using so I recommend
that you go through your phone and
declutter any of the unnecessary apps
and if you find yourself thinking huh I
didn't even know I had this then it's
probably a good sign that you don't need
it on your phone to begin with and this
is a big one declutter any of those apps
that become addictive for you and by
this I mean those apps that basically
suck up your time without giving
anything back in return for example if
you know that social media is one of
your biggest time suckers consider
taking a social media fast where you
delete the app for a certain period of
time let's say a week or a month and
then just see how you feel after that
period of time you may find that you
feel better off without it and the same
goes for any buying or purchasing apps
years back in an effort to reduce my
online shopping I deleted all of my
online shopping apps so basically for me
my biggest culprits were Amazon and
Target and by deleting these I kind of
created a barrier to help with impulse
shopping if you struggle with impulse
shopping just doing this alone can be a
huge help because this now makes it so
that you actually have to open up a tab
and log in and search for the item and
put in your card before purchasing an
item where before it was just easy you
just type it in because it's already on
there everything's already loaded you
may find that just doing the simple
thing can really go a long way to help
you reduce any of that boredom or just
random shopping that you didn't really
need to do tip number two is huge and it
is to disable notifications whenever and
wherever you can I have disabled
notifications on all apps except for of
course phone calls and messages but for
me Duolingo which is where I have my
daily French lessons and I want it to
notify me because it lets me know when I
have missed a lesson so I kind of want
to be nagged at for accountability and
just to create a positive habit but for
those apps that you know you should be
spending less time on or that you want
to spend less time on go in and disable
notifications or at least alter them in
a way that they are less distracting so
that you can still know that you have a
notification but it won't actually Buzz
or beep or try to get your attention
often those beeps and buzzes are the
biggest culprits that throw off our
Focus tip number three is easily one of
my favorites and it is to have a home
for your phone this is something that I
implemented after having kids because it
became so important for me to be able to
have one-on-one time without a phone
physically in front of my screen just to
help me become less attached to this
device because unfortunately the great
majority of people have like a mini
panic attack the moment they realize
their phone is missing because we're
just so used to it being attached to our
bodies whether in a purse in a pocket or
under a pillow which I know is not you
guys right so physically creating a
barrier or having a designated place
where your phone stays when it's not in
use can really help to kind of ease that
separation anxiety so that way you can
get to a point where you can go
throughout your whole day without even
realizing that your phone is missing for
me I place mine in this mail holder that
lives right at the front door
so this way if I get a call or I need it
it's still handy but it's also out of
sight out of mind tip number four is to
sleep several feet away from your phone
if you want to be more productive and
get things done you have got to place a
high priority on your sleeping habits
and making sure that you sleep well at
night I can't tell you the number of
times that I've pushed myself to get a
project done sacrificing sleep in the
process only to end up sick and having
to recover for the next few days so if
you want to improve productivity sleep
is crucial but having your phone right
beside you or underneath your pillow is
not going to help you to sleep well at
night for one the blue light lowers your
body's ability to produce melatonin and
two it just makes it much more likely
that you're going to be getting
distracted if it's in close proximity to
you and you just have to kind of rage
over just to check one more thing before
you go to bed and that one more thing
suddenly becomes two or three hours of
scrolling and by the way if you want to
hear more about how to create a better
sleep routine so that you can be more
productive effective check out my video
on how to wake up at 5am I'll leave that
video down in the description box below
tip number five in order to help you
reduce visual clutter and minimize
distractions use a calming image or even
a blank solid image as your background
color and this can also help you save
battery life I used to swap out my
backgrounds all the time just like
social media had trained me to do and
now I have a landscape photo that is
Serene and calming to look at and maybe
I'm a mean mom because I don't
constantly change out my background for
pictures of my kids or my husband but
you know what I choose to look at them
in person and for me that's really the
whole point it's about knowing what
actually matters to you and reducing
those things that keep you from living
life that you want to live so that you
can truly live and Savor life rather
than just going through the motions tip
number six is to keep only the basics on
your main screen so think of the apps
that you use more frequently and no I
don't mean the addictive apps by keeping
only those necessary items or just the
main things on your main screen it makes
it less likely that you're going to get
distracted by a little notification or
just the desire to check on another app
this way if you go to place a phone call
it just makes it much more likely that
that's the only thing that you're going
to do tip number seven is to disable
raise to wake one of the things that you
will notice with my phone is that it
does not automatically turn on when the
screen is raised
I've purposely turned off this feature
to minimize distractions
so this basically just makes it so that
I actually have to tap or physically
click on the screen in order for the
screen to activate so this way if I
happen to be moving my phone around
without actually having the intention to
use it I'm not going to be distracted by
the phone subliminally telling me look
at me tip number eight hands off utilize
the Siri or Google or Alexa or whatever
you have that can allow you to speak to
your phone rather than being physically
in front of your phone I think I've said
this before but the more hands off you
can be with your phone the better
because anytime you go to touch your
phone it's going to be much more likely
that you're going to do something else
other than what you intended to do I
love using the Siri function I can use
it to send messages to place phone calls
to turn on and off our smart bulbs or
schedule appointments and doing this
makes it so that I can use it when it's
in my little cubby and I don't have to
actually go get my phone or I don't have
to be in front of this screen and then
face the possibility that I'm going to
get distracted by doing something else
the more hands off you can be with your
phone the better tip number nine is
super simple super fast but it can also
help you save on battery life and it is
to go through and delete all of your
search tabs message threads voicemails
calls Etc sometimes we don't even
realize that we have like years worth of
messages on our phones that we don't
really need it's just one more thing to
look at one more thing to get distracted
by so doing this can be a quick little
thing to do that can save your battery
life and just have less to look at less
visual clutter and lastly number 10 use
sleep mode this is one of my favorite
hacks for improving productivity and
minimizing distractions set a sleep mode
to automatically turn on around the time
when you usually go to bed I've
mentioned that I work as a home nurse
and unfortunately my employer does not
provide work phones so I constantly get
messages about work all the time so I
have my phone set to automatically
silence messages and calls at night and
what I love about this is that you can
set specific people on your favorites
that can call you on your notify you if
you want them to so for me for example
they have to call me twice in order for
the phone call to go through and I did
this specifically because for example
when John was a newborn and sleep was
such a precious commodity If I
miraculously got both kids to nap at the
same time the last thing that I wanted
was for my mom to call me just to check
up on me and for the call to go through
so in this case what it meant is that I
had to let people know if you want to
reach me and it's truly an emergency
call me twice I really recommend you
have a set schedule at night that's
automatic that you don't have to think
about but if you have a project that you
really want to focus on utilize it
during the day as well don't let people
invade on your time and energy when
you're really trying to focus on
something that truly matters to you if
you can take anything from this video
let it be this if you don't respect your
time no one else will that's all I have
for today's video I hope that it was
helpful for you if so please give it a
thumbs up and subscribe so you won't
miss when I post a new video I thank you
so much for watching and I'll see you in
the next one bye for now